he is in Wisconsin hi Nicki how are you
hey guys thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up so long story short
I am my brother's power of attorney he
is in prison for the next seven years
and he wanted his three grand in the
bank and he wants me to take the three
grand and buy him coins and I don't
think that that's a good investment I
don't want to touch it I want to leave
it there or maybe put in a CD or
something more safe and he thought I was
wondering what you thought I agree with
you okay okay the the and as his power
of attorney your to act on his best
interest not necessarily his wishes yeah
that's the legal part of it and so you
know in other words if you are put to
the test for misbehaving with the power
of attorney the test will not be did you
abide by his wishes the test would be
did you act in his best interest yes and
so morally you can run the same tests
and say you know what's the right thing
to do for my brother and so if you don't
have a discussion with him the way to do
it is this the only money made in
investing in coins is by people who are
absolutely seriously deep into that
world and love coin collecting and
become experts on it the casual coin
investor the casual classic car investor
the casual art investor the casual
investor in gemstones does not make
money those are all what we call
collectibles in the investment world and
therefore collectors meaning you would
have to know something about them in
order to make money on them you see what
I'm saying and so yeah you know the
coins are not something as a category I
would invest in now again if you're into
classic cars and you want to buy a
classic car and
you love it and it's it's a toy but you
do it right and you probably can
actually make money on it the same
things true with guns or art or whatever
collectible thing you want to put out
there but you got to be it's got to be
like a hobby on steroids you know what
I'm saying and so I know he's he's in
prison for seven years he doesn't need a
coin collection that makes sense to you
and you can tell him I said so if you
want yeah why not
be the bad guy hey Dave said no coins
for you no coins for anybody I got a few
people give me a few but in there nice
is sweet but I don't I do not invest in
those collectible items I have a few
things I collect as I'm a collector but
it's not an investment there's a
difference